first live lecture here we go
international master
dorsa derek shoddy everyone do it up
you're live so great we are live back
with more people than i expected
for the first live lecture so
we are gonna go full blast in
and go for one of my favorite players
fiorusia i have to do it he's pershing i
have pershin
i had no other choice but i'm not going
easy on him for
this one we're gonna look at a game that
he um
kind of played very beautifully against
magnus
for june we had the month full of magnus
and we kind of looked at how beautifully
he plays
yesterday i broke the streak and we
looked at a game that he lost
so today we're going to continue with
that trend and look at how magnus lost
again
and then in the next hour we are going
to look at another game that eliriza
played
this time against levon now did you
think he won
or not whoa whoops
so all right so we're going to go ahead
and get
started with the game um so
with pre pandemic my live audience are
more than welcome to just ask questions
whatever
and i pause for them and i do the same
thing when i'm doing live streams too so
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to ask you questions we're going
to ask
chat questions so should be pretty much
the same
all right so let's get drawing
so this this games were actually very
recently placed last week of june
and they are rapid games and they are
a tournament um they're a tournament
called the gold money asia
i really like the name of it and because
the rapid is expected to be
some weird openings like this
but it doesn't mean that they're not
good opening so if anybody
wants to get inspiration from these
openings i strongly recommend that
because um a lot of the times players
don't necessarily play their strongest
openings
in rapid or they don't necessarily play
some opponents that has like a little
bit hole in it
but it's unpredictable so this was
actually the first round of the
tournament so i made sure
that that's the fact so this is the
first one of the tournament
where elira's playing against magnus and
this is a
not something that he plays frequently
so that's already a little psychological
advantage for
white so um i just want to point out
that knight c6 is also possible i play
knight c6
a lot myself as black so if you play
that good for you
if not that's another option that you
can want to
work on but besides that um
this setup is a screaming f4 sooner or
later there's going to be a 4
probably sooner than later and this
knight
belongs on f3 so that's another thing
that's going to be happening soon
and yeah those are kind of the trend of
the opening
and white does not want to open the
center because white wants f4 so white's
gonna play d3 so white connor already
knows the next few moves
what do you guys think about black how
do you think the setup for black should
be
opening up on the queensland so
center um well since white's opening up
on the king on the king side i would
just think black should open up on the
queen's side
that would make sense trying to go in
the center slash queensland
it does make sense yeah and because
white is trying to do
um king side attack and white is most
likely going to be castling in the king
side
uh at least that's what the opening
trend is uh it makes sense for black to
want to open the center
so that does make sense yeah so i think
the easiest question to answer is
where does this bishop belong now
yeah yep there are lines with bishop b4
as well because it kind of weakens the
e4
structure but bishop c5 kind of is more
natural
and now we're going to continue by
keeping the center closed
because d5 you aren't ready to play this
d5 just yet
after take and um
it doesn't make sense to want to give up
a pawn
it's like white already has space white
you're not really messing anything up or
white so
that makes perfect sense and now
so question is it time to push for tier
is f4 a good idea
maybe not with the bishop on c5 just
because it might be hard to castle
yeah yeah so if you play f4 does it mean
you're kind of committing to long castle
probably okay so
how many of you are familiar with this
opening
like i've seen it before but like um not
very much also can wake up bishop e3
yeah it's possible but bishop retreat
doesn't exactly go with the f4
because white did all these things to
want to play f4 either right now or like
very soon so
tonight knight a4
it's possible but you don't need that
right now
the the the problem isn't with knights
moving the problem
is that you have a lot of other pieces
to develop
and a lot of other um we still have to
decide where you want to put your king
you still have to decide
how you're going to approach the center
so there are a lot of little decisions
to be made and your knight is perfect
where it is
for the time being so yes actually it is
time to play f4
um also yeah the youtube chat is
suggesting some c6
and that's also something that could
come up c65
uh yeah
all right so
we can continue by so this is this is
the world champion it's magnus so he's
not gonna just
play chill moves however if you watch
this term that we had yesterday
uh it was very funny because it was
about the tournament that he had already
won
and it was just the last round so even
if you lost you would win
and it was very interesting to see how
he didn't
um he didn't push for as much oh
low battery
apparently
i don't know where the plug is going
it's unclogged for some reason oh i did
not do that
not this time well that was simple
thanks all right so
yeah um
so it's kind of interesting to see how
players play in different situations
even super grandmasters like magnus so
f4 knight c6 makes perfect sense
huh and
it would be a good idea to just continue
developing there's nothing wrong with
developing you can always
figure out later but the one thing to be
very cautious of is pawn movements
i don't know which game was i watching
but there was like a f5
i think it was a very recent game i
can't remember when i was watching this
and like um not in this position but
pawn structure was that you would decide
very quickly on what's happening to the
center and that's not something that i
would
recommend it's always a better idea to
not make decisive moves with pawns that
that fast all right so what do you think
is the idea behind a6
why did magnus play a6
well i think i know yeah um i think he
won't he played a6 to
maybe go on that a5 since if we didn't
play a6 then he would have like
bishop e3 bishop a4 and bishop
b5 check bishop a4 to get back
yeah you're correct he wants to play
knight day five
so it's not about uh deciding how
important how much do we care about this
bishop
and as it turns out we care about it but
not that much
um something like a4 is
it's what black wants black wants us
he's trying to provoke us to push this a
pawn because if we're gonna do long cast
all
then having moved this pawn kind of
messes with that structure right
so yeah why not just play a3 well even
if you play a3 then long castles later
on will not be very pretty because
this is immediately jumping up and if
you play a3 then you would have to
fight to get shortcast though and that's
not what white wanted in this game at
all
uh so all right white one bishop e3
makes sense but i don't think it was
necessary you could easily just
play something like weird but dirk f1
because you know your rook is you're not
going to castle so you might as well um
you're not going to castle shore so you
might as well develop the rook
uh if you want there's a question on
knight g4 well knight g4 doesn't really
get anything done even if right now
you're playing knight g4
uh you're not you're just attacking here
when i can easily play like queenie
queen e2 or i can easily play rook f1
actually never mind rook f1 there's
night h2 a little tricky
nice i could easily also just ignore
your whole idea and i can attack you
back
and now something like check doesn't
really it doesn't really go
something like knight f2 does not go at
all queen h5 now is white
is winning already so not knight g4
but yeah when ig4 could becomes a
serious idea later on
all right so uh magnus continued with h6
he's stopping our knight g5s
now we could try to play something like
f5 to sever this connection
but it's not a very um serious threat
bishop g4 is not a serious stress
we can simply just continue with the
idea that we had for long castle
because we want to bring this bishop out
we want to cast them so we know what we
want to do with our king so let's do
that
instead of doing on the moves in the
center that we can't take back
all right so bishop g4 now whitetail
what do you think we should do
to be fair you could simply play this
bishop e3 and still
it's okay move but what do you think is
better
i mean the alternative being h3
so extra is like a mini trap style
does anybody want to tell me why h3 is
not good
oh yeah because uh bishop takes f3 queen
takes f3 you get knight
uh d5 d4 that's
one of it but there's something even
stronger than that
i mean you could just play knight d4 yep
basically
also a straw kind of funny lead there is
this knight h52
if you take just knight g3 but i think
94 is the easiest one
yep knight to four is already kind of
white
is in the pickle like minus two pickle
and you move this and then just take
over here at knight h5
yeah so not h3 bishop e3 is a normal
move
but we want something stronger so one of
the
one of the hardest decisions to make
in chess especially in opening slash
middle games is what to do with the
center because right now there is this
tension
so should we resolve it should we keep
it
should we push it well not right now
pushing not before
but so when do you think is the right
time to want to
take an action on this
yeah i think we can take it now because
like our point of playing f4 was
like i i think like opening the f file
i guess we the point could also be like
h like f5 h3 but i don't know
i don't think it's good right now so i
think we can go
fv5 and then like bishop e3 okay so
let's say if i
what if knight d4 are you afraid of that
yeah i guess kind of but maybe just like
queen d1
if not d4 we could simply just go back
to f1
now we're holding this but if we go to
d1 we're all still under the pen so
going to f1 makes a little bit less um
easy for black and now i've take back i
can either take over here
or i can just take over on d4 and then
bring the other knight to e2
and yeah so knight's d4 does not really
present a serious threat at the moment
so taking back it makes more sense for
black too because
also we should keep in mind that both
players are fighting for
the they're not just fighting they're
actually fighting for winning this game
it's not like a last round that you just
need
easy draw and um you just want to get
out of there
that's not like that this is the first
round players are actually fighting for
a lot of money so um if you play knight
d4 you're kind of all
simplifying the position you're giving
your opponent like
when you play knight d4 white only has
one move you gotta play queen f1
and this makes it easier for white to
decide what to do
so kind of like making it more
challenging for your opponent to decide
on moves is a very big part of
the psychology behind chess all right so
take take
and now finally bishop e3 makes sense
right we're taking away the knight d4
ideas and now what if now knight d4 we
still can't take it to the knight
should we take this with a bishop or
should we try to just move the queen
away
yeah i think we should take it because
if we
um like don't and like if queen d1
queen f1 uh black has not f3
and like queen f uh queen f2
i i i don't think that's that good
because like you might take f3 bishop e3
but maybe white still there but i think
with um
taking would be give us a much better
position then
i think queen of two now might be
awesome yeah so the choices between
queen f2 are taking
which one do you think bothers the
opponents more
i think queen f2 i mean you get a tempo
against you
but i mean you can play knight a4 after
you know bishop takes d4 he takes d4
knight
a guess a4
but then you just get i guess bishop a7
and it's not so bad for black that's why
i think maybe queen of two
yeah i don't know i agree like
intuitively
yeah i agree bishop d4 makes it easier
for opponent to decide what to do
before bishop d4 just bishop takes and
now if you long castle then there's like
a
uh black is the momentum or the
initiative i guess
and we don't really want that um it's
kind of funny because
when i first wanted to teach a class
here my first idea was to name it how to
play knowing chess
that didn't really go through because
the word annoying is not very pleasant
so we landed on chess and psychology but
the the whole idea is how to annoy
your opponent until they throw in the
towel so
i don't exactly recommend kicking under
the table but hey
if you can alright so uh queen f2 is the
better one because that's kind of the
kick under the table
the legal kick under the table and um
you're making it really hard for your
opponent to decide what to do now this
is under attack this is under attack
now should the opponent take on f3
should the opponent take on b3
it's kind of a lot of choices and when
people have choice they
sometimes get very overwhelmed which is
actually a term i learned
in my psychology course it's a tight
tyranny
of choices something like that like when
you go to supermarket there's so many
different brands and you're just like ah
you get out of there without buying
anything so yeah
first of all problems but so yeah
here it's a lot of choices for black to
try and decide but i mean the black is
world champion so he's not really going
to
um you know break under the pressure
not yet at least he chose bishop f3
which is
the the one that makes the most sense
your knight here is good
the problem is that this pawn is under
attack your bishop here is kind of done
your bishop's job is done
it doesn't really serve any other
purpose and you would have to move it
around so let's just get rid of it
so take take and black one for knight h5
which i also agree with f4 is a weakness
we don't want opponent to get that the
knight is trying to make sense
now um what do you think white should do
is it time to just
castle or do we have anything else doing
in the center
castle might be premature
because the knight takes b3
i don't know if that makes it harder to
or makes you more susceptible to
like a pawn flurry on the queen side but
yes but if you cast on this knight moves
then it
opens up the d4 ideas
so i guess it's about figuring out
well is it do you have anything better
than castling
it almost feels like you might not
cancel this game
there has been a lot of games that
magnus did not castle
this is only raising right yeah yeah i
guess we could go 94
but like i think castling would be the
best movie
94 huh interesting yeah but
it doesn't really yeah the ship can just
kind of go
get tucked in so we're
keeping the king in the center right now
is not the best choice because
this rook you don't know what to do with
this rook even though there are no real
attacks on your king
the problem is that uh there's still a
lot of holes that black can go and poke
into
and your rook would be completely
useless here
so that's that's why castling makes the
most sense
if there is a tank that's okay we're
just gonna take it back with the a pawn
and uh black will still need too many
moves like at least three more moves and
still to decide for the bishop at least
four more moves to
form any sort of attack so by then we
can all we can
actually b5 just on its own on a5 then
it's also dropping
like there is a potential for the pawn
march but
uh so is potential for us opening up the
center soon
so this gives why it's the best chance
uh magnus did not take it he just went
knight to four
and so knight f4 bringing more pressure
what do you think we should do now can
we do anything fun with our rooks should
we
take any of these knights should we play
like a king b1 move what do you think we
should do
i think maybe we can go to knight d5
because we want to play c3 and also that
nine on f4
um may get like a good annoyance but
there's
i guess not from 95 maybe 92 but like
it doesn't really be right for me
actually 95 is a very
good suggestion too 95 makes a lot of
sense as well
my only um concern with knight d5 is
that yes you are
you're you're bringing a lot of
attacking material
to at the center but at the same time
let's say something like as simple as
queen d6 defends over here defends this
it still kind of holds together and
i agree that knight d5 makes sense but
at the same time
is there any other piece that we should
worry about first
i guess fair point but we can't really
do this right now
are we happy with our king position
or is the opponent happy with our king
position
yeah i guess we can go um king b1 since
like
that e2 check might be an idea yeah
maybe not necessarily 92 but i agree
because like
let's say you play h4 then opponents can
take over here
you take and exchange these and then
something like as
simple as queen d4
i mean that's that's not to say that
this position isn't playable this is
very playable
but um the point is if your king is on
b1
when your opponent takes here you don't
have to take back you can take on c5 and
this is actually what happened in the
game
so now your queen is much more active
than it would have been and queen d4
doesn't work because
yummy pawn and so in the game magnus
went queen d6
now what do you think we should do
just to give you a heads up this game
was not really decided in the middle
game well in the the opening slash
middle game section it was more
decided on the end game section of it
which is so weird for me to think that
magnus lost an end game because he's
usually the one who's always pushing
so i feel like
maybe queen it might be slow but queen
e3 would enable
92 to get rid of that night on f4 maybe
yeah if you want to keep the queens on
the board that's what you should do
that's the best choice to keep the
queens on the board get rid of the
knight
try to push word d4 but
which one gives your pieces a better
activity chance
bringing the queen back bringing the
knight back maybe exchanging and then
again you would have to move your queen
because the pawn takes an attack yeah i
think we should trade planes and then go
like
d4 probably yeah exactly you're
completely correct
trades queens d4 and if take
well great for us this is going to be a
fun pawn
so black's not going to take it so what
do you think black should do how can
they develop their
pieces now oh i see some farsi in the
chat
what do you think is black's best idea
maybe k7
both of them are correct long castle is
good
a lot of stuff arrowing k7 is good too
long castle makes the most sense because
immediately puts your rick in a good
position
if you wanted to play rook d8 without
castling and then bring the king to e7
it's possible but there's still
some questionable holes here that knight
could try to jump into
so if your king stays in the queen side
takes care of these
squares over here and then your rooks
work on
queen center slash king side that will
give you the best chance to win it
so the next few moves are kind of just
well the next move is kind of just
logical you gotta activate this other
crook g1 doesn't
i mean it makes sense but you don't
really have
that much game going on in the king side
from white
so it makes sense to want to develop the
rook because this is the weak pawn this
is
the uh the file that you have the heads
up for
so it makes sense for you to want to
work on that
so rook d2 knight e6
what should you do with this i think i
can give you three choices
push it take it defend it
that's what they did here but is that a
good idea
i'm not sure but i think maybe we can
taking on knight d5
and like i feel like after like review
one why am i have like a slight
advantage
maybe
yes but
so knight e2 was played in the game i
think taken knight d5 is actually the
best sonia
but it's not like white has advantage or
anything it's just a very
playable endgame for both sides and both
sides are still
um fighting to activate their pieces
white has this like three against two
that could become quite interesting
in the long term but this is
not i mean it's not like a super
exciting
um there's not much tactics going on
or even strategy like there are no real
outposts like that you can't push
both sides have enough counter play and
um so knight e2 was the first inaccuracy
that
television made and um
it's kind of weird because then black
got a lot of initiative
right after that so this move will if
white didn't win this game this move
would be
to blame but white one so
spoiler alright so black is beginning
to form some serious threats here
black has a pawn majority on
i mean it's really hard to call this
majority because like
the pawns are so almost connected if
if these two were exchanged off yeah
then it's four against three but still
black has
better chance in the center slash king
side
to want to give himself
a little bit more room to breed so it
makes sense to do this rook f8 and then
push for f5
okay her cat fades d5 was played which
i still i'm a little skeptical on it
makes sense because you're kind of
messing with the knight
but you're pushing the knight to the
side that's that it belongs anyways
so these two moves 92 followed by d5
are not really the the the best
in the position um so yeah knight g5 was
played
and you mean this is under attack so you
gotta defend it
and now pawn is also blocked
this f5 is coming up what do you think
white should do
also this is a serious threat
so what do you think white should do
f1 where you're trying to go are you
trying to push f4
well they forget one first of black
could just do f5
and it's passive because you're just
reacting to what your opponent
is doing you don't really have any idea
of your own
so that's what i don't exactly like
also this is kind of funny um youtube
chat bakken are you using google
translate
because what you say makes sense but
it's not
exact like daily do i am speaking in
farsi
and then there's
but your knight doesn't exactly belong
here
i mean yeah i see the appeal okay let's
say that there is no knight f2 let's say
you want knight f5 i'm just gonna
block it yeah and they still want f5
so it's like you i think it's about
accepting that f5 is going to happen so
you might as well make something else
for yourself
i was thinking about rook c3 immediately
but i don't think that's good that just
blocks in your c3
exactly c2 pawn your card it's harder to
connect your ropes
and your district is already doing
something what is district doing
uh depending i mean
i don't know if that'd be like maybe
maybe after knight g5
f3 would be weak but no i agree rook on
d3 is doing something but the
reconnaissance one isn't
so maybe rook c1 yeah exactly
eric c1 and your cards rook bringing c3
just blocks it so this makes more sense
now you want to push
f5 c4 boom bam work f2
all right now we have a choice should we
exchange these knights
[Music]
he confessed in farsi actually you can't
read it
all right it's kind of fun all right so
yeah um he gets a passport
i think right because i think maybe we
could because i don't really see
anything
else we could do well rope takes h3
rotates e2 and then uh if rook h4
then uh i guess g5 and then if rook
takes on h6
then rogue takes e4 and he's got
a disconnected pass spawn so maybe it's
not so bad i don't know
yeah like my idea was rick h3 rookie two
like g3 you're probably gonna go g5 and
like
h4 takes um and then
routine four yeah
like i don't really see what else you
could do because you're not going to
lose the phone anyway
i agree with that um so also also this
knight
is more valuable than this one it's hard
to explain
um for my third
to sixth graders uh in the virtual
classroom today
i was trying to explain the um
like how uh how to convert your
your advantage and then i got into the
third law of thermodynamics and they
were all like
what what are talking about and that was
not a good choice
but i have more adults here and probably
in there so that would be a better
thing because i wanted to mention that
this night has more potential energy
it's worked more around the board
i've been studying chemistry and physics
i have to
inflate some pains on youtube so yeah
um getting this knife down h3 how many
moves did it take i
actually i don't want to count it it was
way too many um
this knight came from e6 right so that
was two already here
another three here so that's what like
five
five moves this knight on e2 was not
that
actually that night i need to move a lot
too but
anyways i thought mentioning this knight
has more potential energy could be fun
so yeah it's also this knight is more
engaging again and this knight
so uh exchanging it off is a good idea
especially because uh yes this idea of
defending it might make it a little
passive but what about c5
we can still keep it active if you take
it now i can even do c6
and white would i mean you lose a pawn
but
you can continuously use your rooks to
kind of
go after this king you have enough
compensation and it's a
good game so taking honesty would be
good
but ali reza messed up but he still won
so i
can't really blame him so take
now he wanted to uh what others did is
he just continuously went
for this he had literally one idea
and he went for it and but that doesn't
necessarily
mean that it's a good idea just because
it worked here it i
this position is better for black much
better for black
better piece activity better pawn
structure extra material
so don't try this at home make sure that
you
do what your position needs not not a
fantasy
i don't believe in disney so uh
knight f4 is black is much better and
again you have to move the stroke make
you make it more passive
and all right not much happening here in
the chat
i'm gonna ask so i think the main
question that we have to answer now is
how did magnus mess this up
i hope he doesn't watch this stream ever
because i want to say some bad stuff
yeah uh he he he really messed it up
because this is
this is so easy to win sorry i guess
and i think just taking is the easiest
way
knight a4 just move the king away
and if take just start pushing your
pawns because white does not exactly
have
that much ideas these are already
activated
this is already in the second rank just
push g5
it would be an easy game maybe um i
think what happened is
maybe um black started to
overestimate the opponent so he just
started to play a little more passive
and here all right so i gotta ask
what do you think white is trying to do
push
take what do you think
right yeah pushing makes more sense
because
you are already upon down you are
already in
deep troubles with these pawns so
you have to give yourself the best
chance and c6
is that taking just kind of like just
being a
good boy and just letting your opponent
beat you really nice
so we don't want that c6
and roxy8 still mine is still doing
great moves knight a4
again still makes sense
all right so i gotta ask what do you
think black should do now
what does white want
exactly how do we stop it
yeah that that as simple as that makes
makes sense right yeah
uh this would woo
four flies this would be the best one to
do
she did not um i mean then again there
could be some
exchanges here but again black has an
extra pawn and two connected pass bonds
so nothing to really worry about
so k7 makes the most sense uh magnus
point rookie too this is still good
enough
but it kind of gives white a little
happiness
and if you follow my strategy of making
your opponent
super annoyed you would not be letting
this happen
so playing on chess
knight b6 rook c7 again you kind of have
to follow it now
what do you think white can do to make
black
annoyed
i assume white doesn't want to draw i
mean
yes i always think at night uh
knight d7 and then if the king goes to
c8 you go back to b6
yeah why not be annoying yeah yeah
that's it
97 makes no more sense because knight c4
is
also a possibility but then opponent
just takes over here we take
take i mean take and then brooks just
get exchanged and
you don't want to exchange these rooks
not not this easily
because these two pass bonds are not
going anywhere so unless you're
exchanging drugs and eating these two
past bonds you don't want to do that
so 97 makes the most sense if you go
king
over here we are going to continuously
check you
so king a7 see if you were gonna do this
king a7 you might as well done it when
the knight was on a4
right also also do keep in mind that
these games are rapid
so probably a lot of time travel too
okay now again back to question of the
day how to annoy
my opponents why to move how can we
annoy opponents
oh
is everything okay
simp
it's funny though
all right whoa no no that's not
that does not annoy that just makes it
that just makes your opponent happy no
no no no
dirk c4 is the one to do
wait what's wrong with 95
[Music]
well for starter i can eat here
and then yeah
oh yeah yeah that's actually very true
yeah this would make the most sense but
right now you kind of have to go with
the flow let's get
let's defend our pawn first
and
let's see
is it time for black to start pushing
these pawns or should he
still um try to
maybe advance the night the rook is
stuck here the king is stuck here so
either you got to do something with the
knight to try and attack this pawn or
it's time to push these
pawns what do you think is the best one
you all made the same mistake as magnus
that was kind of uh that's so like
um black started to play a little chill
and
kind of messed it because
there is nothing really like there's
nothing fundamentally wrong with h5
it's just when you play h5 you give your
opponents
a new targets now this is weak we can go
start poking at it
uh if you play g5 same idea i can just
bring my knight
block your pawn movements and
then i can continue it with like i can
start pushing my
my own plan so as long as your pawns are
here nobody's really going to be
attacking them
yet yes structure one is coming up
but g1 you have to deal with knight d3s
or you would have to deal with
um actually rook g1 is a threat so
another way to think about it is how to
stop rook g1
or what is your knight doing here
exactly so can we put it somewhere
better
maybe yeah
for some reason i agree night history
makes sense right
no more rook g1s i want knight f2 and i
want to eat your pawn
my position is my i'm very clear i want
to eat pawns
so a knight is 3 would be the most
accurate one
magnus played slightly inaccurate
she lost the game so he messed up he
played h5
uh now a4 it would be a very interesting
continuation but also a little bold
rick g1 was played dirk g1
again kind of gives up a lot because now
after dirk g1
you have a clear idea now black has two
ideas either
you can try to defend this or
you can push it which one do you think
is best
also keep in mind that these pawn
pushing on the
queen side is going to come up
taking the c6 pawn does not really help
because it just take back
and it kind of gives another clear
threat because then you can easily play
like a4 b4 b5
so that doesn't work axle
i agree h4 is the best one
see when you play h4 taking
is kind of too slow h3 rook h7
h2 and even if you try to do
cool stuff just rook g2 this is coming
up
all you got to do is just relocate the
knights both of these ropes
are going to be kind of paralyzed the
knight also can't move
then white is very very under pressure
so
ah this is converting of advantage yes
so this is like you have an extra pawn
and you would give that pawn up
to put your opponent's pieces in a quite
miserable position
and that's also like plus five so that's
besides the point
but that's kind of the the idea that we
convert the advantage and
as long as you don't blunder it well
actually even if you blend it you'll
give the advantage to your opponent so
the law of converse conservation of
energy still stays
so um yeah h4 would be the best
i'm very surprised that magnus didn't do
it could be psychological
that he was playing a lyriza and he
underestimated overestimated his ideas
and didn't go for h4
or he thought his position is too good
that he can do whatever he want
that is never true that's never true
there's no
no such thing as my position is too good
to do whatever i want unless you have
like
two coins even then there's chance for
steel mate so
your position is never good enough to do
whatever you want
all right so g6 was played and
g6 kind of started to blew the advantage
away so how what do you think uh how do
they watch it continue now
alrighty
yeah uh starting with a4 but yeah
the the the chat wants knight e5 oh
boy but the y
do you like do you like magnus so much
you want to let him win at any cost
yeah no that's not going to work
so g6 is the move that's
um probably still keeping him up at
night
uh g6 is bad very very bad
kind of all the advantage away um
rook a4 oh okay
okay for what if i just eat your pond
go for simple stuff eat ponds
yeah uh pawnee four though that's that's
the move now there is a solid
he has majority he can start to
um make black cry so
now one move too late h4 was played
b4 and
before um what if h3
it's kind of funny because after the
move b4 white
white is the one who has advantage
okay sorry i gotta address this too the
one final move that could have stayed
black was knight d3
and knight d3 uh still holds a tiny
advantage for black
you would take over here they take this
it's not it's not as strong of a pawn
movement anymore but
that's the best thing that black could
have done well
sorry what like when you when white
played a4
well like a5
but that's another weakness for me to go
after
but i'm going for checkmate now
it's not just the pawn what happens if
uh king a6 and then if knight
uh d8 you just go back to
uh king a7 i mean eventually going to pa
maybe not immediately well
are you saying like okay let's see let's
say you just ignorantly push pawn
uh let's say kick this away
say i do this again well right now i can
just eat pawn
if you take it back then rook c6
but if you even if you could do b6 not
even b4 works
because then i'm pushing the a pawn yeah
this is a very scary
king position
yeah all right so
there's a lot of little threats like
this and probably
to clarify that's probably why a4 is so
strong instead of
instead of b4 because before like it's
like same ideas right
but before now your opponent gets b5 and
you don't really have that
checkmate ideas that you had you don't
really give your opponent the chance to
make mistake
so a4 is the best one and finally b4
h2 is pretty horrible because b5 and b6
is coming up that's already pretty lost
and even if something like b6 to try to
stop it
now what do you guys think we should do
the game is almost over
i think maybe just like five actually
never mind
the game is already pretty decided after
this move but
how can we try to um
use all these pawns around here
yeah i think b5 is intuitive yeah i
think maybe
a5 i agree b5 a5 now
this pawn is protecting this guy so does
that give us any new ideas or can we
reuse any of our old ideas
yep exactly nice job everybody said that
once the pawn moves
as soon as this pawn moves then yeah
and um if you take it
that'll be a lot of fun so that's
already super lost
and if you try to fight with h3 uh
be careful not to fall for these stuff
because
whoops bye bye night and
as long as you don't blunder and just
follow your simple ideas
it should be good knight f3 is also very
strong because you just stop
these ideas if h2 just right h1 and this
is not falling
so this is another one that would i
think this is a very easy one that would
still hold
clear advantage knight g4 also good but
g2 still gives black a lot of chance
all right so um rick h1 was played
and kind of gave this chance that's why
i wanted knight f3 first
it's because then there's knight d5 and
it gets messy again opponent gets some
chances
we take that pawn and this was the final
whoopsie-doopsie from magnus now what do
you think is black's best move
black has like one move that can try to
hold to summit
to some extent it's not gonna be it's
not that
um that pretty but
what is the weakest what is the most
useless piece in your black's position
yeah so bring it to f7 yeah yeah we rf7
would make the most sense because
you're hoping for some perpetual here if
take
still rook f2 c7 wouldn't exactly work
whoa
wouldn't exactly work because you're not
gonna give check you're just gonna bring
this rook here you're going to threaten
the checkmate
you bring it over boom whoa again what
is wrong with this
yeah you're gonna that's that's how you
get a perpetual
and if you don't push it if you simply
just
uh i don't know i don't really see any
way for you to stop this check check
even let's say bring the knights they'll
check bring the king still same idea
you can't really stop it so yeah
that was the last chance trick f7
recapstone was not played though 93 was
played
but i mean i can understand why rick f7
is so hard to find
so knight e3 was point um eric c3
and this is already super lost and the
next few
moves i think they were just because
magnus couldn't believe he's
busted and as soon as you
give up that pawn that's already lost
not to mention
this is coming up so yeah that was a
very beautiful game that sellers have
played
and kind of whooped magnus so
i'm still rooting for a match between
these two
in this decade so we'll see how that
goes all right that's what i have for
this segment of the class we're going to
take a short recess and
we will be back for seeing how there is
a
got whooped by iranian so this is kind
of fun
all right uh take a quick break and
let's come back to see how ernie
is the king
[Music]
you